whilst it is welcome the headline rate
of inflation has fallen these numbers
show there is absolutely no room for
complacency in the battle against
inflation food price inflation is still
worryingly high that's why we've had
food producers in farmers in
supermarkets in to talk about what we
can do to reduce the pressure there we
are looking at why food prices are just
as high as they are and why inflation
remains High because that's such an
acute source of pressure on family
finances we want to talk collaboratively
with the industry to find out what is
happening of course if there is any uh
wrong Behavior going on we have an
independent regulator that is looking at
those issues but I also want to
recognize that they too are under
pressure they're seeing you know grain
prices very high fuel prices very high
that's feeding into their costs but what
I said to them is we all need to make
sure that as these prices come down the
benefit is fed through to Consumers to
people doing their weekly shop as
quickly as possible